welcome back no you don't have to stop
it oh all right if you must yes
ma'am ma'am put your shirt back on
oh geez Louise
the moles on that woman
does Kamala Inspire hope that Dems say
nope Kamala Harris you remember her
the vice president she's on the left
she's losing support even among her
strongest Democrat backers it's so bad
George Santos is thinking of divorcing
her
as the New York Times points out our
allies are tired of waiting for her to
Define her vice presidency the New York
Times calls it a painful reality that
dozens of Dems including those who
helped elector don't see her as the
future leader of their party much less
the country she know you're dead in the
water when even the times is against you
that or you're on a date with Ted
Kennedy
how dare you laugh can't be too soon I
know even Hillary Clinton thinks kamla
doesn't have the political instincts to
win and she murders people
with acerbic wit
and a knife
made of happiness
which is the name of her gun
so I'd listen to her for sure where was
I for more on all of this we've got a
surprise special guest joining me live
from Washington vice president Kamala
Harris
[Applause]
hello hello Greg
according to the times your own advisors
have referred reporters to democrats for
quotes praising you and even they say
they've lost hope in you what do you
have to say about that
well in order to Galvanize everything
that we have already discussed and
everything that we've already brought
down to America okay I think we need to
understand that everything that we have
uncovered and unburdened
we will continue to uncover an unburden
even more going further
you know Hillary has a history of
supporting all liberal women running for
office but now she's saying you're
doomed what are your thoughts
well you know when it comes to Hillary
and you know I can make a list and send
it to her on her private email but I
think she's well aware of everything
that we have tried to bring and try to
undo
more than what she has done and
accomplished as her time as first lady
[Laughter]
show me Hillary
James kleiberg South Carolina rep who
often backs people of color was asked if
you should still be Biden's running mate
and he'll said he'll leave that up to
Joe what do you think
look I mean look we've galvanized a lot
with electricity and look at how much
we've done with yellow school buses okay
think about the electric school buses
for all the children and they know that
everything that we have unburdened we
will soon burden even further despite
the fact that we have yet to do anything
positive for the country and bring it to
its need
do you uh
last question were you jealous when you
saw your husband make out with Dr Jill
at the State of the Union that was so
great Joe's half dead let her live
well thank you vice president Kamala
Harris you're welcome back to America
[Laughter]
but you do you get the impression that
this is orchestrated now it's just like
this is a plan to get her out you know
it it's really sad because it really
exposes a larger problem in the
Democratic party which is
um when you when you turn everything
into race and gender you're robbing
people of the ability to excel because
you're taking people like Kamala Harris
who we know was chosen for her identity
that was explicitly the case right and
then you're putting her in the same
category as a whole bunch of other
people who worked really hard to get
where they are it's very upsetting Tyrus
I don't know man I think we got to give
her a break like
this building thinks that they could do
a good job
with Rumors in front of them yeah
I think I would be doing the same thing
just huh man I don't know go ahead Joe
you tell them I wouldn't want to touch
anything he's doing either I think she's
just waiting she's halfway there yeah
you know what I'm dead cat you know what
I'm thinking if the New York Times and
Hillary and James Clyburn thinks that
way about her maybe she's awesome maybe
we got this totally wrong thank you yes
maybe I was just being racist maybe I've
learned a lesson
well
I don't think it's hopeless for her
really because we do know I mean she's
as you mentioned it's the identity thing
she's you know she checks the boxes but
she still has that one left
the non-binary Ah that's right
yeah Kamala Harris today then yes
because then she could because she
already did first black first Asian
first female VP she could be first
non-binary VP and first person to be VP
who is both female and non-binary right
I I think I just might have given her an
idea I know I know
that'll make her cackle you know uh Joe
uh is it time for her to fake her own
kidnapping I I think all I think it
speaks to is this I disagree with what
you were saying I do think she's very
qualified for the job I think the fact
that we are scrutinizing her to this
extent for her to Define her role in
this job is speaking to the absence and
again I think it's elder abuse what is
happening with Joe Biden right now I
believe in that firmly I think it is
speaking to the absence of a
presidential leader that we're looking
to see such definition come from a vice
president that's like
that's like being like why doesn't Keith
Richards sing more songs on the new
Stones record you know what I mean it's
like that's not what we're here for yeah
uh but she can't play guitar she can't
no but do you know what that analogy
sucked
I thought it I thought it would get a
bigger laugh
something like Abba
Abba yes yeah
but you know but do you know what I mean
like yeah sorry uh I'm reeling from my
bomb the uh no but I I just don't
understand why there's this pressure on
her to to Define this I I when have we
when was the I I don't remember ever
there being a vice president where we
were all so stunned by except for Cheney
you know Cheney being like kind of just
being everybody said this is a disgrace
he's pulling all the strings and he's
the vice president he shouldn't be
people complain when the vice president
gets too yeah I think that she might be
brilliantly acting like a deflection
Target so the Press can he Praise on
Biden how's that for us really yeah and
then and they still appear balanced by
going after her that is a theory that
came from this brain
I think when I think
what you were saying is is accurate when
when you don't I have never felt a lack
of leadership
more
than I felt in the last six years I feel
like I feel like everywhere we turn we
don't even have state leadership at this
point anymore you know what I mean I was
watching Andrew Schultz's podcast today
and he goes I don't even know who our
governor is like I don't know what's
happening anymore I don't know so when
you're a media boss is in the state that
Joe Biden's in what is she supposed to
do she's supposed to jump up and start
you know I'd imagine
there's elected to be Vice President Joe
you make me sick yeah but I gotta keep
but if you give somebody a job and then
you forgot you gave him a job yeah
that's not fair either you're in charge
of the border and it's true that you
have that paperwork
how the hell can you work like that
that's true she probably passes him in
the hallway and he goes you should call
us I think we might have something for
you
how's the how's the how's the TPS
reports all right we got to go hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else